[Music]
[Applause]
hey Vsauce Michael Cameron
Jake here and we are very glad that you
are here what's going on well it's our
very first Vsauce YouTube livestream
they said it couldn't be done but
actually the technology has been
possible for years and now you've jumped
on and we're going to be answering
questions today we're going to be
showing you the inner contents of our
brains and our minds ask questions over
Twitter send them to at tweet sauce at
Vsauce 2 at vsauce3 numeral 2 & 3
there's ly unknown description for those
oh yeah yeah perfect easy
and then also Kevin is not normally this
flat he is joining us from Pennsylvania
he it just is that dedicated and and
we're also going to be unboxing the
latest curiosity box which is amazing
it's full of science we're going to be
doing some of those experiments but
first things first the most asked
question I'm just going to get to it
because the the most asked question is
why has Michael forsaken us where's a
video wins the new video coming well if
you're watching this live stream right
now you're gonna get it you're gonna get
a sneak peek and you're gonna get some
for one one as the kids say so I've been
obviously doing the brain candy tour
taking science and Vsauce all around the
country we've got more of that coming
and while I was doing that I was working
on a whole series I'm going to do about
should I say say dimensions space the
nature of space and the nature of how
little or much of it we live in the
first episode is about Earth we're all
familiar with Earth and I've been doing
a lot of calculations research and I'm
working with Eric are brilliant visual
effects guy on
some really cool things I wanted to show
you but we couldn't make that work
especially because the computer so far
away I can't even reach to play anything
so you'll have to just you'll just have
to wait I my hope is that it comes out
during VidCon I've also got a really
exciting dong episode coming out then
and you know I appreciate everyone's
patience I am doing dong episodes really
frequently but the Vsauce one episodes
are like my passion on a plate it's what
I've been obsessed with it's what I've
just read 12 books about and I think
it's worth it I think the tackling
subjects even if it takes a while takes
a lot of talking with experts to make
sure everything's right and everything's
kind of novel and it's not just hey I
googled this and here's what Wikipedia
said I think that's worth it but that
said we've got the dawn channel that's
full of content and I don't want to say
too much else about the series that's
coming but you know how I did like a lot
of videos about infinity for a while
well just you wait I I can't even tell
you what I'm doing this summer but I
really hope it's going to open my mind
to things that have never been seen
shown or felt that's all I can say
you're also probably wondering what this
box is in front of me I'm gonna get to
this before I actually get to questions
this was made by a great guy named
Mitchell he gave it to me at brain candy
and it's a jack-in-the-box but what
could be inside of it well I'll just
turn this some musics playing but it's
kind of quiet you might not be able to
hear it
oh it just popped open but but I'm kind
of he's got oh hey it's Michael the
jack-in-the-box how beautiful is that
have you seen this Kevin yeah I think
there's kind of a story of my life but
let's start with some questions the
first one I want to get to came from
Twitter even before the livestream
started and the question was ooh let's
just let's just dive into what what
would our channels taste like if they
were actually so
you can you can here's what I'd like to
do I'd like us to say what sauce our
channel is that's like a real sauce okay
so if there had to be a condom if it
already exists that was renamed Vsauce
one Vsauce 2 and vsauce3 but would it be
who wants to start because I didn't
prepare an answer
I mean I'll go for it I'll start and I
hope I'm not stealing anyone's sauce I
would go with a nice hollandaise sauce
tell me why it's it's rich and creamy
and satisfying but also probably not
very good for you to have a lot of but
yeah I just really like I don't know
holidays was the first thing that came
to my mind cuz it seemed like a little
bit of a more of an obscure one because
no one's ever just like boy I want some
hollandaise sauce right now yeah you
don't really dip stuff in hollandaise
you cover things
yeah hollandaise the question came from
super Dec 64 by the way Declan Murphy
thanks for the question Kevin what sauce
in the real world is Vsauce - well sour
I like to kind of like hopeful messages
with like a little bit of sadness so I
think you get the sweet and you get the
sour so I think these sauce - kind of
covers those two elements of the human
experience
I like that taste experience really I
like that a lot because I think that
sweet and sour sauce is a dipping sauce
you can do things in it but you could
also marinate things in it so it's both
exciting for a second and exciting to
live in okay Vsauce one I'm I'm gonna
say brown sauce good old HP brown sauce
it's more common in the UK and the
Commonwealth but it's basically people
will say I'm not describing it well but
it's like a ketchup with a whole lot
more vinegar and it's brown so it's like
this very adult kind of tastes like it
kind of tastes like maybe an old man
might I don't know but also it's very
serious but it's fun whenever I see that
there's brown sauce around I get very
excited I eat too much and I hope that's
helped
feel about Vsauce they're excited when
things happen and then they overboard
and they but they don't regret it
alright thank you for that question
Declan Murphy it is just ten minutes
into the live stream which means it's
time for us to take out the first item
from the Curiosity box this has been
going on for almost a year yeah it'll be
a year but next month
tell us Jake about what the Curiosity
box is so the Curiosity box is something
that we've been working on for a really
long time and it's a quarterly
subscription box filled with science
experiments science toys books t-shirts
stickers just fun things that we all
really like and what's really cool about
it is that everything in here besides
the book was was created by us that's
right yeah yeah as soon as we start
writing books like the four books a year
that it'll only be our books but these
los videos are great and I think I'll
probably make them for my entire life
but they're only auditory and visual
this is tactile and it's even smell
smell-o-vision
sometimes you can get all your other
senses wrapped around science yes so
take that passive experience which is
video watching it makes it something
that you can share with others visit
exactly so what I want to do is look at
just one of the items first or a t-shirt
that came in the box that you can
currently get at curiosity box comm it
is a mathematical t-shirt it's my
favourite of all they talked about it
yeah let's let's knife this open this is
the safest way to do it this is
literally how the box arrives at your
doorstep it's it's heavy
yeah and it has things cool you probably
can't see it with it cool question works
on the tape and that's one thing we
should mention is that a portion of the
proceeds from every box goes to
alternative research that's right yeah
we've worked with the Alzheimer's
Alzheimer's charities for a long time
and man how how cool is that been like
and how perfect is it for the Box like
the box is all about brain health your
brain elf we're giving you stimulation
that's super smart and it inspires you
to explore but also all the money goes
not just to Alzheimer's charities but
the Alzheimer's research specifically
all right here we go I'm going to cut
this seal off and I
additional math earlier by the next box
we should be at a hundred thousand
dollars donated that's amazing yeah
that's amazing thank you guys for
supporting the curiosity box and it's
you know cause to both put signs in
people's hands and also help Alzheimer's
research it's not just about people who
are at risk or or currently have
Alzheimer's it's gonna help us learn all
about all of our brains here comes the
opening of the box I'll open it so that
you can pretend it it's I'm opening it
look at that it's an octopus named ink
which is short for Kevin it is not short
for Kevin it strikes you short for
inquisitive inquisitive there's a small
version of them yeah so cute it actually
came in a previous box too yeah okay so
what is this right on top curiosity
magazine that's right we write articles
and things that we find really cool that
you're not ever gonna find in a video
like Kevin wrote about the fake rubber
you chew if you want to steal this
screenshot now and that's what you get
okay
Jake open the t-shirt for me all right
here's the t-shirt box and one cool
thing with these boxes that there was an
image it's gonna change actually for the
next one but when this current one
there's an image on every side that
makes a larger image in total but here's
the shirt let's open it up Wow
mathematical so what's going on here
Michael what are we looking at well let
me hold it and see if I can bring it
closer to the camera thickness Emery I'm
actually wearing it ah
Kevin's wearing the shirt there you go
what a great fit oh my gosh
Vsauce makes the best teacher Egyptian
cotton
Wow does does the tag literally say
Vsauce and actually there is no scratchy
tag Wow we must be experts so this this
t-shirt isn't just a fun design that
makes the Vsauce V it is an example of
what's called a modular times table
we've got numbers 1 through 40 around a
circle clockwise and then each number is
connected by a straight line to what it
is times 4 so the number 1 is connected
to 4 the number 2 is connected to 8
there's a line between 3 and 12 and so
on and this can continue as long as you
want if you get all the way up to 40 you
can just start pretending that the
number 1 is 41 and draw a new line we
didn't need that many but amazingly cool
shapes come out of this and Kevin and I
played around like for half a day trying
to find one that kind of looked like
vsauce logo and we found that 1 through
40 on a circle using the 4 times table
looks like a V and Vsauce and that's in
yellow here and does this glow in the
dark oh it doesn't glow in the dark but
future sure it's might so anyway what I
love about it is that it's not just
cool-looking and look at the cool logo
but when people ask you what it's about
you have an opportunity to teach them
the wonders of modular multiplication
like that's a slam dunk that is okay so
any other comments about shirts you can
can you just yeah let's just zoom in on
the guy wearing the shirt for a second
oh good looking that's Jake is in the
magazine a lot a lot of me
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
cute fashion shots of us a few if you
like that kind of thing and yeah Kevin's
right the explanation is in the magazine
so what we love about the box is that
it's not just physics toys and tools and
stuff but you actually get what we think
is a better explanation of the items
then you can get anywhere else or even
if you searched online for a long time
also I wanted to say that I'm gonna be
describing the math behind the shirt in
my next video which like I said will be
coming out at the end of next week while
I'm at VidCon very excited for that one
and I can't wait and it's pretty part of
a series I've actually written two
episodes already in the series so once
once the once the first script is like
where I want it to be then I can film
both and the second one involves mirrors
you may say how a mirror is related to
how much of Earth you can see at once
well stay tuned yeah I can't wait all
right now we're gonna get to other
things in the box but the next thing I
wanted to do is challenge you guys to
some lateral thinking puzzles and
remember all of you out watching submit
questions you want us to answer on
Twitter at tweet sauce at vsauce3
numeral three at Vsauce to numeral two
and we'll get to those after this but I
was looking through my bookshelf this
morning and I found this book that I
have not opened since I was in Middle
School and it's full of riddles that
require you to think laterally okay it's
not like you have to do a bunch of math
to figure it out you have to dive down
or up you just have to dive out and
figure out what could really be meant by
the puzzle all right no I really have
not opened this since I got it so I'm
just gonna randomly find one okay
a man sat perfectly still for eighty
eight hours why hmm
eight hours why let's see how many days
is eighty eight hours it's it's like not
even there's an integer number of days
three hours is seventy-two so yeah then
it's an additional 16 are they all in a
row it sounds like they're in a row
so he's sat still for eighty eight hours
because there's eight eight hours
straight yeah oh it does say straight
let me make sure no it doesn't
separately still for eighty eight hours
oh yeah so he it could not be in a row
so it could have just been over the
course of a week or so he said still for
that many hours yeah but why perfectly
still like what's the is that a clue
it's not just still but perfectly still
maybe he's dead that's what I was
thinking but then I don't know how long
the embalming crosses when you're laying
down well right if he died and no one
found his body for eighty eight hours
then he was perfectly still for that
time that he was discovered and moved
yeah Kevin do you have a guess well how
long does that take
and also are you trying are you
perfectly still it takes three days it
takes three days so eighty eight hours
might be in the right realm of how long
it takes to get to the moon but I've
seen Apollo 13 they float around they
listen to music they do streams with
President Nixon yeah he's still doing
the stream still reason yeah they still
they still well do you think I should
look up the answer I mean let me look on
Twitter to see if anyone else has some
fun than answers the riddle by the way
is a man sat perfectly still for eighty
eight hours why okay
now why I got 48 additional industry
rigor mortis yeah and I think that fits
along with the he died and wasn't
discovered for he sat there because he
had a dentist appointment for eight
hours each week for eleven weeks I think
that could be a good approach like it's
just that we've added up him attending
you know an MRI appointment or he could
be a street performer you know those
guys that like stay in perfectly yeah on
the street there's a statue but this
book was written like in the early 90s
so I don't know where street performers
who froze like popular then I just
didn't go out on the streets back in the
early 90s because I was just a kid okay
there's here's the answer the answer is
chapter four eleven now the answer is oh
my gosh you ready mmm-hmm the man had a
nasty toothache and he went to the
dentist it's at 5:00 p.m. on a Friday
evening the dentist's assistance
including the Ennis anesthesiologist had
all gone and the dentist could not
administer an anesthetic the man
insisted that the dentist should operate
even without anesthetic so the dentist
said that he would have to strap the man
into the chair this was done the dentist
then suffered a heart attack and died
the poor man was left strapped in the
chair and unable to move it was a
holiday weekend and no staff reported
for work until 9:00 a.m. on the
following Tuesday morning eighty eight
hours later and just one I'm getting
some tweets that the audio is out of
sync is it out of sync Eric Eric Eric is
is listening watching the live stream
yeah and then he's gonna look up we
could see what the delay is never again
sound canceling headphones on so he
can't hear us
but he'll hear us in the live stream
talking to him he still hasn't heard he
doesn't know that's crazy so but while
we wait to this I've gotten a lot of
questions about this shipping
international oh yeah it does you if you
go to the curio box website there's a
little drop-down menu on the right
it should show a flag and you can just
choose what country are sorry yes sir
yes it's not see what oh how do we fix
that we put me down okay so we just
heard from Eric that it's his fault he
purposefully made the audio out of sync
and I think what we should do is just
keep it the way else that is it it's a
couple seconds sauce I think that season
I mean we're already 20 minutes into it
so I say we just get to the next item
and by the way this stream is very
exclusive like this is I'm gonna live on
Vsauce 1 forever so yeah I think it's a
I think just deal with the audio being
out of sync and know that you still saw
something very very special because I
have a fear which is that I'm scared
that if I cancel the stream has started
again that it will just go away forever
exactly yeah the great want page you'll
have to go to a new link yeah okay so we
can invest what we do is there if you
want to investigate and see if we can
okay investigate Jake do you want open
the next box item yeah by the way before
we do that though I wanted to take a
selfie of us doing the stream that's how
all good streams start great okay now go
ahead and open it and talk about it I'm
gonna tweet that out okay so what do we
have next
and currently this is the one that is
currently shipping so if you want to
order it you'll get this very box oh
okay we're gonna go to one of the
experiments first so in this box it
comes with inks glow-in-the-dark
wonderful world of slime kit and it
comes with two slimes green and blue
they can make yourself you can create
your own non-newtonian fluid which is
pretty awesome and I've already made one
just for this very purpose to show off
and we can't really show off the
glow-in-the-dark function right now
maybe let's see if we can I have a black
light but it's too bright in here so
it's not really let's see if we can pull
up I got that
let's let's maybe if they get really
close and put it in the shade hmm not
really I'm really but it looks cool give
it a poke while you're up close okay
like an ASMR video look stripping well
it's only my laptop that literally it
might the script for my next video is on
containers so you can keep it and just
make yeah make some slime and play with
it so that's one of the experiments it's
really cool there's a little Kevin back
there playing with it
yeah the box isn't like this isn't
someone else's slime this is packaged
glasses way of sauce sly if you open it
actually Michael if you want to open it
it comes with a whole entire guide about
different kinds of slime snail slime and
yuccas what non-newtonian fluid is what
a Newtonian fluid is kind of goes
through the whole thing oh there yeah so
this is the booklet that comes in the
box and like I said it's not just hey
kitchen science slime isn't slime cool
it's how would be sauce do kitchen signs
in your home well we would provide you
with a giant book evil of what slime is
scientifically how animals use it what
it is that you've created what
glow-in-the-dark means it's really
really cool non-newtonian fluids the
whole thing about that we got a picture
of Isaac Newton in there this is a
Vsauce video in your hands for a good
cause curiosity box.com somebody even
made Noah linning made an unofficial
subreddit for the Curiosity box oh did
he
I love I love that but let's go to a
question so this question actually
chilly try just I have a question yeah
go ahead boys yeah
should we just try and because I think
what we can do we're all gonna problems
on the ceiling I think if we just
unscrew and start again it will be at
the same watch page are you sure yeah so
we could just let's just do that cuz I I
don't want to the delay is probably
annoying cuz they're saying it's five
seconds and that's not very good
oh it's night we'll be back in probably
15 seconds maybe more like 30 No
here I go so let's start again okay it
is ready okay so now we should be back I
believe okay hopefully that fix some of
the audio problems and it is getting
really hot in here this way to turn off
the air conditioner so that the audio
would be better and oh my gosh I should
have gotten a sweat rag alright now this
is a question I'm curious to hear what
you guys think because we we talk about
science and YouTube a lot we talked
about memes sometimes this came from the
subreddit meme economy oh yeah
and they asked with Norma fication an
economic bubble happening so often with
memes what is the best way to find
stable long-term memes with good growth
for those of you who aren't followers of
the meme economy let me explain that
it's basically a Nasdaq trading area for
memes and jokes and they rate how fresh
a meme is like if you've got a whole
bunch of them ready to share are you
gonna get a lot of likes on you know
Facebook or reddit or Instagram or
wherever you put them or is it already
all an old meme are you gonna look like
you're lame and they track the
popularity of memes and I said Nasdaq
but they call it Nasdaq obviously the
question is what's a good way to find
stable memes that are good to invest in
that will always be funny or at least be
funny for a long time and won't be and
will the bubble won't burst meaning you
know some company tweets the mean and it
completely becomes not funny and
subversive it there's still an audio
delay which means I think they're just
going to be a delay yeah okay sorry so
Kevin did you hear the question yeah
exactly
so the question is a mean will pop up
and it'll be funny for a while but then
inevitably you know my mom shares it on
Facebook and then a big company does and
all of a sudden it's not cool and
subversive anymore I like go ahead and
and so how do you what makes a meme more
likely to be fresh for a long time and
not burst I think it just has to be kind
of withheld within a certain zone and
not turn into training moment yeah no i
100% agree i think that elements that
make something less likely to become
mainstream like being way too niche or
you know in a lot of cases it's just if
a meme is offensive it's never going to
be shared by companies it's never going
to become mainstream and i think that's
been the story of human culture ever
since it began you know like if
something was too palatable to the
masses it would lose its kind of like
edge right it's coolness so let's see
are you guys seeing other questions
coming in that you like thank you meme
economy for that I should really do a
whole video on that topic and I've
wanted to because there are all kinds of
social theories about how long it takes
for something to become lame and then
come back like beards for instance
beards were cool in old tiny days but
then for like my dad a beard was
ridiculous that's what old men had so so
I grew up with the whole generation of
adults that didn't have beards and so
when I got a beard it was like yeah take
that I have my own identity and and you
know I think my kids will probably think
that beards are for old people and
they'll all love shaving so hey good
long-term investment razor blades that
you heard it here first
any other questions you want to do
oh here's a good one
Gaga D asks do you say gif or Jif good
question Kevin you answer first I've
always said give I didn't hear jiff
until later until I kind of already made
up my mind that it was gift so it wasn't
really an instance where I was going to
say you know all of a sudden switch it
to two Jim plus I love making peanut
butter guy Jeff is a peanut butter so
I'd like to keep that in the realm of
peanut butter and gif in the realm of
you know animated images um so I do know
that the creator of the format's said is
pronounced jiff print however I go with
gif I mean obviously he created it but
gift it's unique it's different jiff as
Kevin planet has already taken and also
if we do want to be honest about it
it is graphical not drown out your
ethical so it's still the same obviously
that doesn't mean that it has to be
pronounced gift and not gift but for me
gift is is what it's most reasonable
yeah you know what
I pronounce it jiff all US gift sorry I
pronounce it gif and it's all for the
same reasons I am a language description
astiz correct is what people do not what
some rulebook says that would be a
language prescription estándar stand
that the creator of the word says that
it should be pronounced jiff because
they had the whole like choosy
developers choose jiff
you know slogan but here's the thing it
became so popular that the creator no
longer owns it and that's a sign of huge
success you can hear this from like I
think George Lucas has talked about this
in the Star Wars like it became bigger
than his own personal thing and all of a
sudden you realize that it's not you
anymore but it's you and the fans and
the viewers and if all your viewers are
calling it a gift
because Jeff is what I guess I don't
know how it gift became more common but
you just have to surrender and say
society's chosen yeah I mean if everyone
started calling vsauce vsauce i would be
upset but i would understand that if
that
the common way to refer to us then
that's the way it would be yeah I'm
gonna do one thing real quick you have
to move this sister we're all aware and
we move the webcam off and this mess
around with the computer and see if I
can delay the video so it matches with
the audio okay cool but Noah's just a
pet peeve that I have I like
problem-solving technology all right so
so you'll keep the camera pointed at us
so they can't still be pointed at you
make sure it's like lined up so you get
Kevin ah Oh Oh drama shot how's the note
maybe a little bit uh I like that you
like that bald head people will think
that yeah they're you don't keep that
okay and let me play with the computer
okay cool okay so for those of you who
have just joined us the most asked
question is when is Michael gonna make a
video I hate him he has forsaken us and
that couldn't be further from the truth
I have done nothing but work on a new
series that it's like my infinity series
but it's going to be about dimensions
and that next video the first video in
that series should come out at the end
of next week this week if you believe
the Week starts on Sunday I'm really
excited about it and it's taken an
enormous amount of reading I've actually
written the first two videos that's why
it took so long I just like got so
obsessed with mirror images that I wrote
a whole other video and then I was like
ah but I should film I'm also working on
a project that I cannot tell you about
until VidCon starts it'll be announced
there and that's what I've actually been
very busy with it's why I went to London
last week to interview an amazing person
and we're here to answer your questions
send them over Twitter in fact I'm gonna
look at Twitter right now and answer the
very first question that I see the very
most recent are you guys ready this
could be dangerous
the newest question is the video was
already delayed the audio came before
the video not a question the first
question is when did Vsauce start and
why Vsauce
turned 7 years old in April of this year
7 years I've made hundreds of videos and
Jake and Kevin you guys have also made
hundreds of videos it's almost crazy how
deep that archive gets after seven years
with like no Bray
that's something a lot of people don't
realize probably about us that we're not
like TV where we don't take some kind of
break between seasons you know where we
actually don't work at all not all TV
shows are like that but as soon as I put
a video out I'm working on the next one
but it's worth it because every video is
different and it's always something that
I'm insanely passionate about it never
feels old it never feels like a job and
that can be tough like for my wife who
is like why are you working and reading
and I'm like well because if I didn't
have a channel I would be reading the
same book right now but at least at
least because I I have a youtube channel
i can build a conversation about this
book and show other people all the cool
things that scientists and
mathematicians are doing so that is very
cool Kevin any questions coming in for
you you want to answer now there was one
that I think that you know we get a lot
and that's you know just any general
advice for people trying to start a
YouTube channel and my advice is always
to just do videos about stuff that
you're interested in it doesn't make it
feel like work you know what Michael was
just saying is definitely truly whenever
I haven't been working on a video it's
always because I'm really excited to see
what it looks like when it's done
and it doesn't feel like a laborious
activity at all so often I think that
people get this stuff on this idea that
they have to make videos that you know
that they think other people like or
something when it's really like sort of
a marriage between like what you want to
see and you know obviously what what
other people want to watch too but at
the end of the day you know you really
should just be talking about and working
on video
that is exciting for the process and the
journey and building and not just like
the end result the end result is kind of
like a present at the end that you get
to unwrap and it and enjoy for a day or
so but you know for all of the time
leading up to that it's it's gotta be
fun and exciting yeah 100% agree I
there's such a balance between making
sure that people are happy that they're
you know getting videos that they want
to watch that they expect from you but
also you have to evolve yourself and
keep challenging yourself because your
audience also evolves they're getting
older they're seeing things they're
getting used to things and if you keep
doing the same thing all the time
they'll eventually move on you need to
grow up with your audience and sometimes
that means you know changing up a format
or you know I mean I used to do shorter
videos now I do longer ones cuz I was
like well this would be a lot more
difficult I'll do it and I love a story
about Pixar and how they they used that
to motivate every movie they made you
know they made like Toy Story and
everyone was like that's cool but can
you do like millions of creatures moving
all at once and they were like screw it
we're gonna do a movie about ants you
know and they did it like they they they
literally chose that topic because it
was something that people said they
couldn't do and so that's why when
someone tells me you can't show or help
people visualize the fourth dimension
and actually see a fourth perpendicular
and I'm like perfect that'll be an
episode I'm gonna do I'm spilling too
many secrets about all the work that
I've been doing and all the videos that
are gonna be coming out soon but I'm
gonna reopen this box and I'm gonna pull
something else out of it what do you
think I should look at next Jake the
posters all right so here's some
coasters and as you may have noticed
we're not using coasters today but
that's because we're gonna wait till we
unbox them here's my glass of water
these are glowing beverage LMS I love
these because not only are they cool but
there is shout-out to a video I did
years ago so coasters protect your
tables but these also fill your mind
each coaster has a atomic symbol on it
we've got vanadium we've got sulphur
we've got the gold and
still inside here we have cerium if you
put these all together it of course
spells Vsauce
but what's really neat is that if you
turn them on they light up can you see
can you see it lighting up of it pull
the tab out that's how fresh this is can
you see is it lighting up check that out
because it's so bright in this room
we've got extra lights on us that some
of the glowing properties aren't
happening here the Skjold ones working I
don't know if you can see but when you
put a glass down on it boom it glows
purple yeah so you can find your drink
in the dark and you can also appreciate
the periodic table you can spell the
word Vsauce this came from my video
about what's the most precious metal and
actually when to the University of
Nottingham and I did experiments with
all four of these elements vanadium gold
sulfur cerium it was it was sweet those
guys are so great Brady Haran is amazing
and I mean thanks to him for letting me
work with all of them and do those
experiments Jake is actually he's in the
same room but he's working on the audio
delay so can I save your bookmarks yes
my laptop is the one we're streaming
from so you're gonna bookmark all tabs
just call it like livestream save and
then okay so from the LM mats haha get
it elements elements I'm gonna move on
to the polymer spheres look at that
packaging that is called a premium
experience these spheres the tiny little
beads they're made of a polymer that
absorbs water like insane it loves the
hydrogen bonds that water molecules have
and although they're small I'll actually
open this test tube up so you can see
how small they are
they absorb 300 times their weight in
water so there they are teeny tiny
little beads
and earlier what we forgot to put some
in water overnight but I put some in
about an hour and a half ago inside one
of our glasses this is one of the
Curiosity box beakers and it's full of
little beads okay you can see that it's
down at the bottom there little tiny
beads you fill this with water and they
expand at 300 times their size this is
what they look like after just an hour
and a half that many became this they
are full of water and the clear ones
have the same refractive index as water
so if you put them in water they become
completely invisible plus you can dry
these out and they go back to the small
size and you can use them all over again
you can also squish them if you want I
think I'll talk about this beaker
because it's in my hand
but beaker is one of the goals of mine
is to make things that are both tulle
their tools in two ways this one is a
tool that helps you carry liquids but it
also lets you measure things so rather
than just telling you 50 milliliters 75
100 we also put down some comparison
some funny unit of measurement so for
example if you fill it halfway up to 150
milliliters the the mug actually tells
you that this is the volume of blood in
the human brain yes if you only want
that much coffee you gotta get the
Curiosity Box beaker okay so Jake we're
still streaming but what are you trying
to close all the tabs I'm trying to
close all the tabs both sides is the one
that we're currently in oh I just can't
pull it out cuz I can't find it's so far
I have about two hundred and three tabs
open because like I said I've been
researching for two episodes and I've
got all the links open because a little
to likely through the tabs like a book
you know or like a notebook full of
ideas I could see the tabs getting
bigger so this look it easier okay do
you think the problem is the number of
tabs was causing issues with the
bandwidth feels better
yeah because what's gonna happen is it's
using a lot of your memory and also your
CPU yeah yeah definitely so if we can
close all these tabs and we should get
more out of the encoding software
alright so here's here's a question that
I want to get to because I had an answer
prepared and let me see who it came from
because I want to give
to the oh okay here we're gonna do a
question from dragon Beck's urn Stuart
it says on Twitter
Stuart asks which video did you enjoy
researching about and making the most
and why
Kevin probably the video that I did
about dragons all the millions here war
just because that's something that I've
always been interested in like even as a
kid you know dragons are always part of
fantasy video games you know Final
Fantasy and and movies and once I got
interested in like where the origins
were of that symbol you know it just
became kind of like a you know wormhole
or rabbit hole that was really exciting
to read about so there was another
question on here not workflow and I'll
just kind of tie that into this you know
one of the things that I do often is if
I have a topic like dragons I'll just
search Amazon for every book that I can
find okay has been written about dragons
well in a scientific manner you know not
just narratives right well I could just
grab a pile on than just a show ya show
pile of the books I I've got a pile of
books over there that are related to my
next episode and the one after that yeah
but it's really fun to read a book and
then look in the bibliography and see
other books that they read in
preparation for theirs and then read
those and you wind up finding that a lot
of these authors or friends they've
talked about things together or they've
inspired each other and there's no end
to it but I think you can only make a
good video when you're really
well-versed on what's happening and
that's why they episode sometimes take a
while the delay is better now yeah well
just because I'm sorry we're gonna
interrupt for a second it's just because
of how many tabs we had open I was
afraid of that when we started using my
laptop but it was the one that was just
already logged in to the Vsauce you see
let me reset this up there's a close-up
of Jake's hand it's a good look in the
hands any palm readers out there let us
know we
yep what's good to me you can tilt it
down a little bit
great okay hey welcome back okay cool
so so we can't see ourselves anymore but
that's because you wanna be able to look
at the health of the stream and also
okay so part of what's going to be
happening is in my mind and this isn't
factual but I just believe it to be true
is that if we have the actual
application open and running on screen
that it might use extra resources or
breath because it'll be prioritized and
it's the one that so however now
everything should be fine we just Eric
and I just listen to the audio it sounds
a lot better so let us know if it's in
safe now and now we know not to try a
stream with 200 absolutely yes yes and I
hope you saved all those tabs cuz
otherwise I might be able make a video
for another four months I did okay so
Jake thank you for your a lot about very
first Vsauce live stream ever Jake while
you were gone we got a question from
dragon bucks urn who asked what was your
favorite video to research and why
favorite video to research and why is a
great question dragon okay think about
it I'm gonna answer that it's not my
next one but my next next one I've been
researching it since February that's how
long it's taken I've had to build things
I've had to reach out to people who are
much smarter than me and I just keep
adding things to it and I'm like well
should I do an hour-long video should I
make a do 17 days straight the visual
effects work for it yes obviously yes to
both of those questions and generally my
answer that question is my favorite
episode is the one I'm working on right
now because that's why I'm working on it
it's a topic that I was like so curious
about I wanted to dive into and I can't
wait to understand it well enough to
explain it that's how I feel
you know you you've wrapped your head
around something as well as you can
appease when you can explain it to other
people and your curiosity about the
topic is contagious to them then you've
done it you know but of course I wind up
looking at old videos and now that I've
had like some time away from and I go ah
there's a better way to have said that
or there's a better way to explain that
so I think you're gonna see a lot of
kind of callbacks and a lot of
clarifications in this new one I'm
actually investigating like literally
the episode coming out in about a week
I'm gonna talk about a claim that I made
in my earth is flat video that Kansa is
flatter than a pancake Kansas is flatter
than a pan well wait a second
the reason I'm correcting it is that
more precisely Kansas is smoother than a
pancake but Kansas is not flat because
the earth isn't Kansas curves along with
the earth and crazy enough this is gonna
spoil one of the fit the facts from the
video but that's why you guys are here
you're the livestream people and you
deserve the best so if you stood in the
middle of Kansas people on the west and
east side of the state would be 200
miles away in each direction and if you
can see through the earth you would
actually see them about eight kilometers
below me that's almost the height of
Everest it's like one kilometer short so
they'd also be like tilted at a two
degree angle so Kansas is not entirely
flat at all it's curved and it's curved
such that it's almost like standing on
top of Everest if you could see people
on the other sides if you could like see
through the curvature of the earth it
was transparent or something that's
pretty neat okay so Jake what do we do
next
now that you've made the stream perfect
what's happened what's what's what's
that's good or answer another question
all right so how would a Kansas pancake
tastes well it would taste like a
pancake because it's literally just a
really big nice one Nicholas Meredith
how did we meet
ah yeah so it was a OkCupid comm is how
that's not true OkCupid comm by the way
could have been how we met you know it's
been around for like 20 years
apparently long as I've been around yeah
Jake's Jake's gonna be 24 this year
we're very excited for him he'll be able
to rent a car almost in New York yeah
and and and how long do you guys think I
am a lot of you probably know I mean I
know I'm not gonna say you you you you
say first let's see if people on Twitter
are giving us any guesses but I hope we
meet well we all met blowing business it
was a staggered story Michael met Kevin
because others say your story and then
you can fill the blanks Michael was
doing YouTube stuff and Kevin was doing
YouTube stuff and Michael saw it was
like this is really cool and reached out
the Kevin said hey Kevin you should do
some videos for Vsauce because this is
back when a sauce was more of a gaming
comedy channel and there was multiple
different hosts right let me clarify
that
Vsauce was a comedy channel problem is
that wasn't very funny but Kevin was
funny and I was like dude you're making
funny videos like literally the burst
was I was like can I give you money to
put up one of your videos on Vsauce like
literally it was a video you would
already put on YouTube wasn't it yeah it
was an episode of Julius blue
yeah the first two videos that I did for
Vsauce we just re up loads of videos
that I did on my channel that you
actually intro and then re-upload it on
Vsauce that's right how weird like I
would never do that today but back then
it was like there were even fewer you
know rules and experiences and
traditions and then Vsauce 2 started
like the same year Vsauce one day
because at the time it was a trend
everyone had a second channel that was
literally the numeral two after their
name in retrospect I wish that I'd
called it you know
Vsauce Green Vsauce blue Vsauce violent
because then they would kind of stand on
their own better and instead the number
system makes it look like there's a
hierarchy which there isn't but Vsauce 2
was where I could do stuff that wasn't
comedy related but was a little more
educational that wound up working a lot
better because I was better at that than
trying to be funny and also was hard to
get access to like game footage and
stuff because we weren't IGN we weren't
some big company that everyone knew and
then I think it just became obvious that
having one person per channel and kind
of leading it from an individual's
personality worked way better they're
called channels but they're not they're
really like shows and if you have a lot
of different formats on one channel
people get confused so I said Kevin why
don't you just take the second channel
and do whatever you want they're like
it's just yours and then Kevin and I
were going to lunch one day and we saw
this homeless guy on the street and he
said I really want I can't figure out
what to tattoo on my finger we said well
have we got the logo for you now I'm
just kidding tell tell tell your story
uh Jake yeah thanks I was well I started
working at Google in 2011 and Michael
and Kevin were also at Google and we
just kind of became friends and I was
running a space focused channel at the
time that's right space lab yeah Space
Lab I was doing Space Lab and we always
kind of became friends as we worked in
the same office in New York and it just
blossomed
yeah we we should explain like wait you
mean you worked at Google yeah we
literally worked at YouTube the long the
long story short is that when I first
started making YouTube videos I was
hired by a company called next new
networks and I worked on a channel
called barely political and then I
created Vsauce and then YouTube
literally acquired the company the next
new networks and so I became a Google
employee and they were really hands-off
they just wanted someone on staff who
knew how to help advise other creators
to get the most out of YouTube to make
the best content they could build
audiences and I had a channel so I had
experience and as Jake and Kevin join we
became like three people who all had
experience who were all literally
walking the talk and that was really
great I'm you know goo
so hands off like they didn't know what
we were doing or win and they never told
us what to do hey you know I mean they
would they would have us help clients
like they would say hey you know this
person or this company's gonna do some
Olympics videos could you help them make
them like a little more exciting more or
educational or surprising or you know
whatever and so we were doing that for a
long time and then it was just last year
that we we all left and became
independent so now yeah we have our own
office
that is a Vsauce office kevin has a home
vsauce office and he looks on the other
side of the country and you know after
after that happened I moved back to the
United States from London cuz I was I
was working for Google in London so
that's a really good question I think we
could probably talk about that story
forever mm-hmm should really just write
a book about it put that in the
curiosity box all right a lot of
questions coming in now should we do
another item yeah yeah take the box Jake
I'm gonna look through some questions
yeah do that one and while you talk
about it answer this question from Sarah
Nicole nine one two three who asked on
Twitter how do you decide what goes in
the curiosity boxes okay so that will
lead into kind of this one so in every
box we also have a steam game for Mac
and PC so in this money it's called dub
words and dub or has actually had a very
interesting way of getting into the box
where I I do a lot of work with Taco
Bell and they have like that they have a
program where they help game developers
indie game developers make their games
and get out there and stuff like that so
this is one of the games that was part
of it and the people who made it were so
nice and the game is so cool that we
were like can we just feature it in the
box so they gave it to us and let us put
it in the box and it's really cool and
this one you basically it's like a
top-down shooter but it uses music as
the weapon so it's kind of fun and I'm
gonna scratch off the code and whoever
wants it whoever gets it first can just
get the game
if you if you're the one who actually
gets the game let us know because I
always wonder who winds up winning these
kind of events let me put that others
down for the free games there's the code
is it focused it looks like it's in
focus so there's the code and there goes
some really cool indie developer game
glad to help him out yeah like if you if
you are the one person who got the code
I would recommend you know if you really
like a game write a good review on Steam
because you know the better they do
that's awesome that's great they're a
small company does to people and they
made this entire game themselves over
the course of years but so more like
Michael we put stuff in the box in Kevin
that we just find to be curious that's
interesting to us there are things that
we've liked in our lives or that we see
like oh wow we need to make that we need
to have that yeah and it takes a long
time to like source and create the items
that we need for the box so we have a
whole list and it's like months out
before we actually have confirmed that
we can get get it in I remember the
gyroscope was one that I was like guys
this is first of all like a classic
physics toy we have to get one in the
box and I've always wanted to do a video
about how gyroscopes stay up because I
don't know why so okay it's gonna come
out when it came out in like the the
holiday box from last year I was like
great so around the holidays of 2016 I
have to know how to explain gyroscopes
in time because a lot of people in
beginning them man it was so fun you
know like I I had the the luck to grow
up around science stuff around cool
polymers around periodic table toys
around gyroscopes around things with
weird properties and I think it was
great for my little tiny little Michael
brain and the Curiosity boxes are a
chance to like do that we already make
videos and we'll keep making videos
obviously but to get the science in your
hands and connected with the videos
that's one of the big goals of of the
box I'm just going to grab this sticker
right word and big thing what like this
ink plush probably took what maybe six
month
to actually make yeah oh and also hold
that you plush up it's about the same
size as this one in the back I don't
know if they can see it if you yeah but
that's an optical illusion that her
parents sizes are the same but let me go
grab this big one and show you its
actual size while I walk away check out
the back of my shirt it was an easy
question we can answer while Michaels
doing that Kevin what's your favorite
band this is from McDaniel on Twitter my
favourite band right now is probably
Paul Bearer which is a do metal band
they just put out a new album called
heartless that's really amazing but I
also really love Gojira which is a
French black metal band they came out
with a new album last year called magma
and if you guys earned a medal you
should definitely check out their super
talented and their lyrics are always
really cool and kind of atmospheric and
esoteric they talk about kind of like
science stuff it's less like Bohr and my
evil things that a lot of tomato lyrics
are our focused on so I don't know I
think if if you're a pea sauce pan and
into metal you definitely like what
Europe for sure how did you get into
metal do metal especially um I've always
liked metal I think my first cassette
tape because I in that old was actually
Motley Crue dr. feelgood so I mean I was
five years old now your your your wife
is really into it did you get her into
it or did you guys have that in common
no we just had that in common so yeah
but yeah I'm always like I've always
liked Mel since literally I was a little
kid so it's not like something that I
fell into when I was a teenager or
anything like that it's it's it's pretty
much what I've liked always yeah so my
accent I love to Michael Jackson when I
was like three yeah men by the age of
five imma chilling to motley crue it's a
natural progression story is oldest I'm
Jake
favorite band right now oh right now
yeah not like well I'm sorry just
favorite band I don't mean to make it I
went through my favorite band that's the
most meaningful to me if such one is
growing up is modest mouse yep like
Interstate 8 moon and Erica that stuff
like those albums especially those two
particular are timeless to me won't some
crowded West look like any which is
really good but I think mood in America
is one of my favorite albums on the
planet I could listen to that endlessly
it's just so beautiful and and haunting
and I just it reminds me of being in
high school and like driving through the
plains in Colorado right so this this
shows how much hipper and younger I
guess Jake is the me because Modest
Mouse's earlier albums remind me of
being in college it was like that's all
I listen to so I would say that that's
my favorite band of my life right now
I'm listening to a lot of Angel Olson do
you know her
I think I found her feel her work with
Cass McCombs and she's incredible and I
also really love black moths super
rainbow and tobacco same same guys
behind both of those their music is so
trippy it's so great I've even tweeted
some playlists of songs I like and I
always include either a tobacco song or
a black Mouth super rainbow I saw them
live I saw a video of them performing
live at a radio station I've never seen
what they looked like I'd never seen
them play and I was like yeah I picked
well this is awesome
and one question we've been getting a
lot on Twitter is people asking about
why the curiosity box doesn't come
their country ah so what you can do is
if you go to the Curiosity Box website
there's an email there and this email
and request the the country because the
basic ganas answer is that we have to
create kind of shipping agreements with
different countries so we can get it
actually there and get it at a
reasonable price and not an insane thing
that has to go through customs so we
just need to know that there's actually
people who want there before we go
through all the negotiation processes of
getting it shipped there so email so we
know that you want it there and then we
can start actually making that happen
yeah yeah exactly because our goal is
for this to be available to everyone
just like the videos that we make on
YouTube you know we could we could like
you know sell them to you on DVD but
then we want to reach more people we
want more people to catch the curiosity
bug and fall in love with these topics
it's gonna be laserdisc only laserdisc
only they still sell cassette tapes at
CBS you know that yeah I think they're
used in medical equipment or something
still anyway but but that that made me
think of my favorite thing about making
videos is that I can pick any topic like
it's almost a challenge to try to pick a
topic that sounds the most like bizarre
the brick ista crone problem was one of
those like no one can even pronounce
that why would you do a video on it do
one about black holes
everyone loves those and I'm like
everyone's gonna love the geometry of
cycloids they just need to like be
introduced to it the way I was months
ago and I want to do like a series that
just tries to get more and more boring
like the physics of how paint dries or
how grass grows or I guess I did that
minefield episode where I was in a white
room for 72 hours that's about as boring
and lacking in stimulation as you can
get let's talk about this sticker
because this shows a side of us they
showing off at him cuz he can talk about
it we can show it yeah Kevin talked
about a sticker oh yeah so you know we
wanted to put a sticker in a box that
represented Vsauce in in a unique and
kind of new way and you know what I
thought was to come up with this this
tree and it wasn't just any tree it was
you know a nebula tree so instead of
leaves you know it's it's it's it's
gases in outer space and the roots
themselves spell Vsauce
so you know the nutrients and the water
that gets absorbed into this
cosmological tree that's good sauce you
know that's kind of like the
communicator of this like heavenly body
yeah yeah it that doesn't sound crazy it
sounds I don't cover up the website
curiosity voxcom yeah put it there yeah
I love it I love it also like we we
worked for a long time on this to make
sure it was it was the way we wanted it
to be and because we can include
t-shirts and stickers and things you get
to see is the kind of aesthetic side
that we have that you might not always
see in videos because those are more
fact-based you can actually I mean Jake
your your content is so cinematic now
that it's almost like we do get both but
mine are always terrible except for what
Eric makes my little two-dimensional
Photoshop animations are like hey this
is what was in my head and using only
two dimensions and some rectangles
here's what I think it is Dylan waffle
says have you discontinued minefield I
love minefield
it has not been disken
you'd next week you might hear exactly
what that means can you tell that I'm
winking but I'm also for those of you
who are just now joining dedicated my
number one priority is Vsauce one videos
the regular things that you guys come
for and it's been a while since my last
one because I've been writing scripts
many of them I want to do this whole
series about dimensions and space-time
is a dimension as well but I love the
spatial ones because of the
impossibility of imagining more than
three or is it is it an impossibility
tune in to Vsauce open to find out more
subscribe sapphire asks I don't know if
you guys are Doctor Who fans it was an
easy question go ahead
sapphire ask who is your favorite doctor
my favorite doctor is David Tennant I
think he was the best doctor and he is
just so cool love him love Dave where
was he in the order so he came after
Eccleston okay so in the new series he
was the he started the second season
right and then I prayed with Matt Smith
that means nothing to me
I'm not afraid to admit this but I have
not gotten into Doctor Who yet oh it's I
know but tinit I should be looking out
for their where do you start
that's one of those they're the thing
you don't need to the way that the when
the series was rebooted you don't like
they do references to the original
doctors and the original episodes but
it's more of like kind of Easter eggs
like hey you know this because you're a
big fan you can watch the new ones
without that I think you need to start
with Eccleston and then from Eccleston
and he in my mind was the one that I
kind of related to the most in his
personality and of the way that he
expressed himself and interact with
others Kevin do you have a favorite
doctor um I'm more between Peaks guy do
Twin Peaks if anybody out there is
watching that it's really weird yeah I
can't wait I can't wait to get back into
it so I wanna you don't need to watch
the first the earlier episodes do you
because really no I mean it would help
if you spoke with someone like you could
ask me for like a primer right I can
give you in about 10 minutes
well I wanna I want to watch the earlier
ones and I tried to actually back when I
lived in New York I bought a very
discounted VHS tape collection of all
the Twin Peaks episodes but they were
labeled out of order so I watched them
out of order is our connection bad it
says bad that's more of really just the
Wi-Fi okay so so shadow kills three two
one asks is this the next box coming in
July or is it the previous the box we're
opening right now is the current one if
you go to curiosity box calm and and
subscribe now you'll get everything
that's in this box we haven't even shown
you everything yet but the box that's
coming out next is don't listen we're
your ears my favorite I can't believe
how awesome the next box is it's like
but that's also one of our goals like we
care we have this opportunity to like
lower the quality of the box that's
never the point you guys know what our
videos are like you've been watching for
years
it's always about yes but how can I make
this more difficult for myself and
longer and better
it needs to be a challenge it needs to
be a challenge and so this one I think
is the the best of any that have come
out so far the next one is even better I
mean there might be a day where we
it went downhill a little bit but it all
just be for a reason oh yeah it'll be
because it actually isn't the worst
there's something you know what I mean
so but this one's really I mean but the
thing that should be noted is that the
next one is incredible as of this one
but to be able to get the next one like
to make sure you get it you should
probably start with this yes it's locked
in for the next one because we only make
so many this isn't like made on demand
so if we run out it's sold out and that
happened last year with the gyroscope 70
the last two box outs have in the last
two boxes so we wind up with people
subscribing they can't get the newest
one we came up with a solution for that
which is that if you subscribe and we've
already run out of the currently
shipping box you get what's called the
best of box and it's our favorite things
from all the previous boxes you don't
need things from the previous boxes they
don't connect it's not like you you know
you shouldn't start midstream but you
will get one right away and it's gonna
contain some of our favorites so if you
want the next one the coolest I can't
even tell you everything that's in it
but I've been working with but even the
game the game is worth almost as much as
the boxes yeah the game of the segment
is literally huge literally what I see
what you do in there I like it I like it
yeah and it's like I think it's the
first box that is the one is it's taken
us like a year to put it together we're
like I want this and I want this thing
and I want something that looked that
establishes this principle and allows
people to experiment with this and it
took us a year and it all lined up to be
the next box and that's gonna keep
happening for all the next and next and
next ones and all through next year it's
gonna be years of preparation before you
actually get the box mm-hmm so let's go
to the next item in here what should
that be I think let's do that okay okay
so we also have collectable items
this one is a collectible enamel
pin and it's a ink or little octopus
friend the mascot of curiosity box which
before I get to the pen why an octopus
well I'll tell you why
and this i'm retconning here because
this isn't exactly why it began but if
if the curiosity box is the hands-on
science version of these sauce videos
the mascot should have a lot of hands
now octopi don't have any hands but they
do have a lot of arms eight of them in
fact so he represents the like actually
touching and holding things and
experiencing them live in front of
yourself which is you know miles better
than just hearing an explanation
anyway this pen has ink wearing a diving
helmet and some floaties on two of his
arms which by the way makes no sense
because he's an octopus you should be
able to breathe underwater but you never
know what to expect
that's why it's the Curiosity Box gettin
a lot of questions about the simulation
theory that Elon Musk has been has been
talking about a lot yeah and the reason
I want to mention that we don't really
go to in depth because is a little bit
of a spoiler for what an upcoming
vsauce3 video I'm actually making a
video on that topic with the YouTube
channel in a nutshell so we're gonna do
a two-part series on that half of it
obviously on the Curt cigar channel and
then half of it on vsauce3 but that
would be coming hopefully in August but
yeah that's the topic of the video that
we're working on that'll be awesome but
that question comes up a lot too so I
can't wait and man working with in a
nutshell what a great channel we
actually did we put them in the magazine
in the past or was that wind over that
I'm thinking about
we put wind over yeah so the magazine
that comes with the Curiosity box also
shouts out some of our favorite
educational channels yeah this one is
let me just confirm yeah yeah with no
reproductions and we also feature what
an artist that we like and this
it was kit McGrath who Kevin I both
followed on Instagram independently and
realized we both love them you probably
following me now you probably found out
later because you you're such a follower
who kid more girl yeah yeah yeah
so he's busy looking at questions while
I'm trying to rhythm but the point is
that yeah we we use the magazine also
has a chance to shout out what else you
should be watching on YouTube Jake's got
an article about film kevin has one
about rubber I have one about numbers
and number names and how how the first
number alphabetically is 8 in English oh
yeah
the second number alphabetically do you
guys know don't look no eight billion oh
you know maybe your billion eight
billion eight is the third I'm gonna
literally go through all the numbers
alphabetically eight million 18 million
eight billion
18 million eight you're okay you're
dropping balls so I better stop okay can
I open the last item in the box yeah
open the last item so this one is really
cool so this is why the box is so big in
heavy because there's always a book in
the box and this book is especially cool
you actually getting a lot of questions
out elements its the elements it's a
really cool heavy book and even has the
covers actually custom printed for us
and it has the Curiosity Box official
logo on it and that's really cool it's
something I've been doing in the future
a little spoiler little tease if I may
is that I believe the next book that
comes with this box actually has a
custom forward bias yes yes it does and
in the book that's in the next one I
grew up with and I loved and I've never
found anything like
before this is what my dad used to have
and you should've shown some of the
pictures it's video tells you about the
element and then shows you how its
applied and they try to show you is pure
the sample yeah it gives you like atomic
weight density atomic radius the crystal
structure of the electron filling order
all that stuff but this the photos are
really really nice there's also a poster
in the back of the book that is a
periodic clay that I love I have and all
these photos are on that poster that
comes in the barn
yes sir please put in the whip Eric
hey so so Sadaharu 98 just said whoa
whoa whoa it's octopuses not octopi who
said octopi I didn't say octopi did I
yeah you did I said octopi all right
well let me say again that I'm a
language description estai think that
even if something is technically wrong
if everyone understands what you're
meaning then you're fine however I
totally am on board with you in fact in
the magazine that comes in the current
box if you subscribe today or if you
already do you have this there's
actually an entire the very first pages
from ink but it was written by me
because spoiler alert ink is like a
character and not a real thing but I
wrote this and what and it's it's all
about how you're right the plural of
octopus is octopuses or octopodes
activities there's the poster wow it's a
gift that just keeps on giving that's
really cool so that's all of this let's
just wrap up the box up real quick and
we can do some more questions yeah
they're perfect perfect but that's the
the latest curiosity box that you can
currently get again curiosity voxcom
it's a great way not only to support
vsauce but also to support alzheimer's
research
yeah we are getting very close to that
$100,000 donation mark that's
that really awesome yeah and it's just a
fun thing and all these items are in the
in the latest box so you can get that
and then it also puts you reserves you
for the next box which is going to be
amazingly even better than this one we
think it's it's a massive yeah and I'm
doing so many videos around it that
it'll they'll probably sell out right
away so you should subscribe now because
you'll be really sad otherwise we only
make so many of them oh where did it end
it's your audience oh no one spill any
secrets oh because this the software's
frozen this weed you minimized it okay
yeah okay one second gang I'm just gonna
start was the last thing that I said oh
no the audio is coming through that's
fine okay look yeah the video stop but
you guys can still hear us yeah so so it
should be coming through again camera
froze yeah okay health is good so I
think it should be back it it looks like
Kevin is dabbing in the freeze okay oh
we're still frozen on this that's the
issue it's the camera that's frozen yeah
so let's just Johnny now it's gonna work
there we go let's go back to that nope
okay so we're just gonna have to go to
our webcam you're just fine which ten
there we go
we're not frozen we should be like wow
look No
hold that was like the the mannequin
challenge yeah that's what we're doing
right now everyone aren't we amazing at
it and see this is oh there we go
unfrozen maybe tilted a little bit yeah
I don't actually the table Nick burns
company computer guy okay all right now
that so many things we're back so so I
don't know if everyone saw the book but
we were talking about the box and how
proceeds from the Box go to Alzheimer's
research we've raised almost a hundred
thousand dollars for Alzheimer's
research because of this box
Alzheimer's is something that affected
my grandfather and it was extremely
extremely difficult so I flew out to
Chicago and I worked with biologists and
a chemist at the Alzheimer's Association
and they taught me all about what we're
doing where research can go what we can
hope for in our lifetimes and I'm so
grateful to them I made an episode about
it if you haven't seen my episode on
Alzheimer's go check it out because I
don't know if there are a lot of
resources that really dive into the kind
of biology and chemistry behind the
disease and how it's different from
other kinds of dementia there's a lot of
misconceptions out there and it's really
appearing as this like next thing as we
make progress on heart disease and
cancers Alzheimer's and dementia is kind
of there waiting for us it's all beyond
that natural selection shadow layer you
didn't have to live to be 80 90 100
years old to reproduce and so natural
selection didn't fix that it's like
really up to us so so so exciting to be
working with Alzheimer's charities on
furthering research yeah the thing
that's affected all that I remember like
having to towards the end of my
grandfather's life introduce myself to
them every time did I go this is your
grandson Jake any be like oh hello and
where are you going to Skype in college
I have to tell them every
time Liberman to college and who I was
and it's not a fun thing so we want to
try and help that as much as we can
let's look at some questions now we're
taking questions over Twitter at tweet
sauce at vsauce3 numeral three at
vsauce2 numeral two a lot of good ones
coming in shout them out if you find one
that you were really excited again I
think I might have just fixed that again
I'm trying here I'm only one man
no very small thing much much meat on me
I also like to point out this t-shirt I
think is pretty cool is that like the
Japanese the actual poster yeah the
Japanese poster for Star Wars it's kind
of cool we should say Happy Father's Day
to all the father's out there watching
and happy Father's Day to all of our
fathers yeah because you know what up
daddy if any of you were recording this
you can use that for memes in the future
yeah one question that I think is an
easy one to answer we didn't get too
in-depth into it is uh what's your
favorite video game favorite video game
look on answer first because I know that
least about video games I still love
home world you remember that back the
era
I loved the slowness of it it was like
playing chess with yourself because you
had so much time and it was this 3d
strategy game and I would I would play
and then when I couldn't play anymore I
would just go outside and ride my bike
and talk out loud about strategies I
might
do it was like because back then you
couldn't watch other people play video
it were no Let's Plays there was no
YouTube but I did exactly what people do
today when I wasn't playing I was
watching other people play or I was
talking about the game yeah no great so
I'm just gonna jump in because homeworld
was was buying see where it's published
by Sierra yeah
Sierra also published my favorite game
which was the original half-life yep
developed by valve published by Sierra
that game changed my life because our
first time where games like cinematic it
felt like you know you were experiencing
the the theatrical moments in real time
it wasn't a loading screen and then
break and it feels like a cinematic
pre-rendered thing is happening there
and then all the modifications that you
create for we're excited I can make
different skins for characters I can
make different models I can make my own
maps and then play out with them I met
with my friends yeah that was really
cool for me so half-life is my go to
Kevin - it came called Xenogears which
is for the PlayStation 1 it's a it's a
role-playing game and I just think it
was the coolest story not only in video
games but it's one of the coolest
stories that I've ever encountered I
mean it takes place across thousands of
years and it involves science and
philosophy and psychology and religion
and just in capital encapsulate it's
kind of like all of what humanity is
about and there's mix I mean it just
kind of has everything and if I had an
endless amount of money to dedicate
towards remaking
we definitely go towards an updated
version of CEO gears because they they
didn't even finish the story the second
off lab is I mean you can read about
this if you want to the second disc is
just just sums up what was gonna happen
with the story because they kind of ran
out of time so it's this weird thing
where the game doesn't even really in
the right way it has like a cliff notes
second it's it's it's weird but it's
amazing I'm gonna talk about the Orange
Box real fast not this orange box but
our number was living in New York I had
a weekend with nothing to do and I
walked to a store and I bought the
orange box and I played a game called
portal I'd heard about portal but I
hadn't heard anything about it I play it
I like oh this is kind of neat I also
like that it's not about working really
quickly I like solving the puzzles but I
had no idea what was coming in the end
and I played that all game without
leaving the couch all the way through
all the way through the night and I was
like what I got so scared it was it was
an amazing experience that you cannot
replicate with just a movie or a book ed
portal so the thing that was such a
surprised by that is that it wasn't
really even one of the main selling
points of the orange box you got like
the new half-life chapter trapped like -
you got Team Fortress 2 I think you also
got the old games for half-life and then
there was just this little thing called
portal yeah oh this is gonna be a fun
little like 30 minute diversion but it
was incredible and the sequel was so
much fun
I remember playing that with my friends
cuz you can do co-op mode in portal 2
right now can I say that I had him just
with one of those thanks to Eric
everybody with me you guys later could
you would you play with me because I've
never played portal 2 why because I
played portal 1 on a Playstation and
PlayStation 3 I think right it would
have been yeah 33 yeah and I wasn't good
at the controls I was like I just wish I
could use a mouse yeah because I played
World of Warcraft like crazy it actually
kind of was almost a problem and I
leveled up a lot of characters to the
max and whatever but I got I really
enjoyed having a mouse to look around so
I want to play Portal 2 on a PC but I
don't have the system at the moment to
play it and I don't want to play it on a
console because I don't think I'm good
at joysticks yeah it is it is more
difficult for fur mouse and keyboard
being able to y-yeah than my little
mouse there but there's also something
for like the simplicity kind of a
concept of Oh grab the controller sit
down and some games are obviously that
are designed for that than others is
there like one or two more questions
that we want to answer before um before
we go yeah like one that I liked was um
No do you think maths exists or is
discovered that's a tough one I'd like
to do a video on it I think Roger pin
roses book what does it called the road
in reality touches on that the best but
it's a huge heavy thick book I believe I
don't even know what to believe I think
that we we invent a lot of stuff
mathematically but then it happens to
already exist in the universe and so
it's a combination of Hey look what I
invented it's called an imaginary number
ah well it's imaginary must not have any
real existence and then a hundred years
of years later we go it does what the
heck it's so useful and helpful so yeah
I think it's a combination of both also
there's one dudes been tweeting on ours
say that's your name and I apologize if
I pronounced it
I'm a horrible human being thank you for
showing your friends our videos that's
very nice of you you are a very nice
person you know what I'm gonna give you
a wing that was just for you that's yeah
everyone close your eyes everyone out
there don't watch your eyes keep your
eyes open
did you do it because I close my eyes -
you didn't yeah everyone open their eyes
okay great you're welcome arsh okay so
when is the next vsauce video coming if
you've just joined it should be coming
in just about a week I really appreciate
you guys as patience the episodes that
we all make are you know they're not
cookie cutter things they require a lot
of research and I have wrote written
actually more than one episode so I'll
be filming those really soon it's all
part of the series that I do we kind of
like how we did a bunch of videos on
infinity for a while but this one's
going to be about space and the
philosophy of dimensions but the first
the first one is is like a quick
introduction that kind of got me excited
about things and it's about how much of
the earth can you see at once that's my
next episode and I started to just you
know I keep asking why and I never am
happy with an answer I just want to say
but why that but why that and a lot of
my script was about how the further you
get away from Earth the smaller it looks
but I wasn't happy with just that I
wanted to know why why did things appear
to look smaller when you go further away
and the answer is just a very simple
geometric reason but I wasn't happy with
just that I wanted to know why do we
live in a universe where angles work
that way and that took me to dimensions
it took me to their independence their
linear independence from what
another and then all of a sudden it
became what my next year these videos
are going to be okay I just want another
question yeah I think this is a pretty
important one
and this is for mr. avatar and he says
what do you think about pineapple on
pizza Kevin you go first
well you know I think it's okay I don't
have a problem with it per se would I
ever order it explicitly I don't think
so but um if I was very very hungry and
there was pineapple pizza you know I'm
going for
Michael I want to piggyback off of Kevin
but you're taking can you guys see what
Jake's doing with the balls the polymer
balls with they're overflowing because
they're filling up with so little water
just these balls are what come in the
current curiosity box if you subscribe
at the website that's how many were in
the mug before and that's what it looks
like now and it doesn't ruin they're not
even done growing it takes like 12 hours
from the foveal so cool they feel really
cool they feel like probably eyeballs
and you touched eyeball before Oh
multiple times hold someone's eye boy
after I murder of people I just always
take out their eyeballs and I like to
eat them but what am I'm a little bit
like yeah Kanawa story is all this time
so okay I'm on a pineapple on pizza I
think you know Kevin I think really
encapsulated there the vsauce spirit you
know I don't hate anything I'm not full
of hatred for for any kind of pizza
topping i I might find it fascinating
that some people have very strong
opinions about pineapple on pizza I
don't I don't eat pineapple on pizza I
have I don't always like it but I think
that it's part of the experience of life
and if you count it out you're not
experiencing the universe in its
totality so I have a much more
abbreviated answer which is I love
pineapple
I think it's delicious pineapple is one
of my favorite fruits on the planet
I'll have pineapple anything so yeah
kind of on pizza I also just like normal
pizza and that's that's that I hear
something yeah I do this this is a nice
question
Pablo asks what advice would you give
someone who wants to make educational
videos but are afraid to fail ah
I'll step one don't be afraid to fail
yeah that's I mean failing is the only
way that you learn if you haven't failed
that he didn't try so that's just a good
metric they have there and also you're
never gonna do it amazingly your first
time there's always going to be
something that you did it seems pretty
good there's always something that could
be better that maybe it wasn't up to the
standards that you originally thought
and you just improve every time that you
iterate so don't be afraid thing that's
the hardest robot but I'm sure you guys
feel this before making a video public
yours I know this is the worst thing
I've ever made yeah but I just need to
do it you have to push yourself past
that point that that wall that you have
and just do it because if you don't do
it you won't know if you succeed or fail
to begin with what's that famous sports
quote that I know about sports which is
you make are you a hundred oh yeah it
was a great right so it's you you miss
100% of the shots you don't take Wayne
Gretzky Michael Scott yeah yeah it's
from me well it's from Wayne Gretzky but
but no that's right it's not for me if
Michael Scott quoting Wayne Gretzky and
when you quote someone you should also
let everyone know that yes from you so
so yeah Jake I think your hundred
percent right I think if you're if
you're afraid to fail then you're gonna
have to be the biggest failure of all
time cuz you don't even start you have
to always be making bangs and saying
that they're finished because once it's
finished the lessons start to gel in
your mind and so I don't ever feel like
something's perfect but I put it out
anyway especially when Vsauce was was
just beginning I was doing
like IMG type episodes I couldn't make
those longer I could put more things in
them but I just wanted to get them out I
want to get them out because everything
you do is a lesson and so you should
make and make and you should always make
things that challenge you don't ever ask
yourself but what do viewers want
because we live in the Internet age we
live in a time where no matter what you
do there's gonna be millions of people
on earth who are gonna find it
interesting and the problem is when you
start to guess what they want or you
start following what other people are
doing and you you get lost in the crowd
be yourself and I know that's super
cliche the cliches are cliches for a
reason they work and you have to really
embrace that if you if you look at a
test tube and you're like why are test
tubes this shape where's the word test
tube come from what's it to you - what
if YouTube was a real tube but if it was
a pipe and video data went through it in
form of DVDs how wide would the pipe
have to be all of a sudden that's a
Vsauce video actually that's after seven
years I could just go but but yet you
should you should do you should answer
questions and and explain things the way
you would explain it as if it was a
friend don't think of the audience as a
huge mass of people in a theater think
of it as one person your friend and you
sit down nice safe dude have you heard
about the Banach tarski paradox okay
like here's this cool thing here's
another cool thing and you just dive
into it this is a television anymore
where people are you know tuning in
halfway through Kevin any questions
you're seen coming and you want to
answer Derek as if we'll get the one
that we just unboxed yes this is the the
one that's currently shipping and if you
want to make sure that you get the
second one they're not the second one
the next one after this then you should
probably start with this one because
that puts you in line for yeah and this
one might sell out so you should sign up
as soon as you can because it's a bummer
when you miss out and unfortunately
that's just the restrictions we have
like the boxes is very like premium it's
not like oh yeah let's just crank out
some more it's like how many can we make
okay cool
let's get these to everyone that we can
and then yeah I really want to also
start making videos we haven't we've
talked about this a little bit I want it
not not making videos on the curiosity
box channel as well where I can go
through all of the really cool kind of
sciency things that I have geometric
toys and weird elements and stuff
because I did that desk to it with Adam
Savage and I was like holy cow I've got
hours of content here mm-hm
but the next Vsauce one video has been
cooking for a long time it's actually
been the next - I can't wait to get
those out in fact just Friday I was
working with Erik our visual effects guy
on how we see and last night I had this
like amazing idea well I shouldn't say
amazing because it's actually probably
not that good you won't know until until
I dive in and see how it looks but I
want to talk about how it even this is
such a be sauce moment I was like how
much of the earth can you see at once
well what does it mean to see it's gonna
be like a bunch about even how the eye
works and how vision works and the
properties of light but I will
eventually answer the question so don't
don't worry yep Michael make it a good
one do you have one I don't know okay go
ahead it better be good what do you
think that you would be doing if not for
you - ah great question I mean before
youtube I was writing music and a band
play guitar and sing
and wrote songs so it probably would
have kept doing that I think that I
ended up going to youtube because I'm an
introvert and being a musician requires
going out and playing gigs all over the
place and traveling so YouTube is a way
for me to create stuff well just be at
home so my creative energy into YouTube
so anyway have stuck with musics Jake
I've been making videos on Vimeo so you
would still be making videos yeah I mean
before I did YouTube I was working in
advertising and television making
commercials so I'd still be making
videos the thing that was just so
intriguing about YouTube is that it's
it's yours
right like you know you write it you
host it you edit it you direct it
everything is is your interpretation of
what you want it's not somebody else's
and that to me is very exciting but I
still be I'd still be probably making
videos just not as happily as I am
currently I would probably be working at
a university because before YouTube
before I started making mashups and
edits for the first time I was working
dude briefly as a research assistant at
the University of Chicago in a psych lab
and that was what I thought I was gonna
do I was gonna go to grad school I was
going to pursue degrees in Euro
psychology and then when YouTube
happened I started making things and
some of those early like Hillary Clinton
farts videos got seen by millions of
people and I was hired to do that
professionally and I thought well this
won't last forever I'll eventually go
back and all work in as a researcher and
and then no I I became a science
communicator and I celebrate what actual
scientists are doing who are way better
and smarter at everything
but I love being a kind of bridge to get
the public excited and kind of get their
heads wrapped around how important and
cool science is I've got a few questions
about Eric if they can see Eric who Eric
is reveal yourself Eric story
come on over here what
pick pants on all right here's Eric this
is Eric welcome to the stream you're
just in time for the end yeah so just to
wrap it up is mostly getting some
questions about the box doesn't ship
internationally if you go to the website
you can choose your country of origin
and hopefully it's there if it's not
then there's an email that you can hit
up but the boxes are that we really
really care about and it's an expression
of what Vsauce is but it's ten well you
can touch it you can hold it you can
share it it again helps support not only
sauce but also alzheimer's research and
so they're really really proud of we
spent a long time making even this like
a lot of the items in this box remember
the ink one in particular I think we had
already had this designed and stuff in
like December of last year yeah and it
took all this time that doesn't have it
manufactured and approved and up to our
standards so it takes a while and it's
something that we really really love so
hopefully you like it and check it out
any other kind of things Michaels
working on a new video they come out
during VidCon would ya soon
and of course I've been I've probably
made more videos this year than any year
in my life because of the dog channel if
you guys aren't already subscribed to
dog check that out because we do
obviously as you see way more projects
than just the Vsauce channels we try to
put science in people's minds in every
avenue possible I do the live show brain
candy live we're gonna be back on tour
in the fall maybe I wasn't supposed to
tell you that but whatever all will
delete this live stream afterwards but
anyway that's science like actually
brought to you we've got the dog channel
which is a safari around the internet
showing you the coolest things people
have built online that you can do online
now guys dong and you know what honestly
follow our social media because a
YouTube video takes a long time to make
we
these kind of you know pieces that are
labors of love but if you follow us on
Twitter I'll have everyone share all of
their social media now but if you follow
me on Twitter tweet sauce on Instagram
electric pants you're gonna get content
almost every day especially little
things that I want to show off a little
like geometric things I've built and and
science and physics that I I can't turn
into a big video that like you would
expect but I want to talk about now
follow tweet sauce and electro pants on
Instagram Jake you've got your social
media handles which I mean I know them
but yeah so there's either Vsauce
straight that link is down Kevin eyes
Vsauce Twitter's are in the description
or you can follow my personal level
which is Jake or awr yeah I have to on
Twitter and Kent
Lieber just just my name is Eric ever
now it's just in Atlanta for a couple
days you can see some of the eclectic
mix of people that I met while I was
there wow that's so far don't know yes
he actually is a YouTube channel where
he's done some like Lydia he did one
video about the effects on your what if
the world what if the world ended the
one that was like very 80s and
opportunities that it's so cool
eric is brilliant with the visualization
and the making of beautiful beautiful
things that teach so thank you to him
thank you to you guys check out
curiosity box calm to help Alzheimer's
research and to get Vsauce in your hands
too
to your door we are going to get back to
work we love everything that we're doing
we love you guys and should we say yeah
and as always thanks for watching and
now I'm going to everyone freeze and I'm
going to walk over to the computer
refrain anything and I am going